نع الى غزه ومتابعه التطورات المرافقه
لاستهداف منزلين في رفح ومعنا من البيت
المستهدف لعائله الحجاز في شرق رفح
مراسلنا مؤمن الشرفي مؤمن تقف اذا على ما
بقي من هذا المنزل انقل لنا مشاهداتك
هناك نعم الوضع هنا اكوام من الركام انا
اتواجد في المنزل الملاصق تماما والغرفه
الملاصقه تماما لهذا المنزل في هذه الغرفه
كان ينام سبعه من الافراد بينهم بينهم
اطفال وهم عائله نزحت الى هذه المنطقه بعد
نزوحها من المناطق التي تعرضت للقصف في
مدينه خانيونس ووسط القطاع هذا الركام هو
ركام منزل عائله حجازي التي تعرضت لغار
وقصف اسرائيلي بعدد من الصواريخ على رؤوس
ساكنيه ودون سابق انذار من بين الشهداء
اطفال لازال العمل والبحث جاريا عن جثماني
طفلين استشهدا نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي ولم
يتم العثور عليهما حتى هذه اللحظه لكن
الجهود مستمره من قبل شبان من من نفس
العائله ومن جيران المنزل للبحث عن جثماني
الطفلين بادوات بسيطه جدا في ظل عدم توفر
امكانيات سواء من قبل الدفاع المدني او
المعدات اللازمه لازاله الركام لانتشال
جثماني الطفلين اللافت في هذا الامرا من
بين الشهداء عائلات نزحت الى هذه المنطقه
بعد قصف اسرائيلي طال منزلها تحديدا في
عائله الهمص هي تعرضت لقصف اسرائيلي سابقا
في مخيم يبنى وسط مدينه رفح بعد قصف
المنزل ونجاه باقي افراد العائله توجهوا
الى هذه المنطقه لتلاحق الصواريخ
الاسرائيليه مره اخرى ويستشهد
جميعا كما تشاهدون
ايضا الاعمال البحث لازالت جاريه هنا
وايضا هذه المنطقه تعرضت لغار تين بعدد من
الصواريخ هذا المنزل منزل حجازي وايضا
منزل قريب جدا من هذه المنطقه هي منزل
عائله الهمص والمنازل المنزل نفسه منزل
عائله حجازي كان يؤوي عائلتين نزحت الى
هذا هه المنطقه من مدينه غزه بالاضافه الى
اضرار ماديه كبيره في المنازل المجاوره
وايضا سقوط شهداء وجرحى في جيران المنزل
المستهدف من شده الغاره الاسرائيليه
والصواريخ التي استهدفت هذا المنزل
والمنطقه في ساعات
الليل
المتاخر
هنا
نستضيف ايش شهاداتكم ايش اللي صار عنكم ه
في المنطقه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مع
الساعه 12 تقريبا 12 و5
هيك مع الساعه 12 125
تقريبا حصل زلزال بمعنى الكلمه زلزال في
البيت فكنا نتوقع انه يكون هذا في نفس
البيت اللي احنا فيه طبعا احنا نازحين من
مدينه خان يونس وبعتونا قالوا لنا انه
روحوا على رفح لانها مناطق امنه لا اعرف
اين كيف امنه يعني وم الحمد لله على اساس
انه نايمين وصغار اطفال ونساء وهكذا لا
عندما استيقظنا وانا اغمي علي في حينها
وبعد ما ادركنا الوضع وبحثنا تبين انه هذا
القصف في الدار المجاوره اي بيت ايمن
حجازي عندنا في المكان هذا بنتي واولادها
سبعه انفار كل الردم هذا وكل الحجار هذه
كانت فوقيهم الله لطف استشهد طفل بريء
عمره حوالي سبع سنوات في هذا البيت اللي
احن فيه وحنا البعض بعض الخدشات والحمد
لله لكن وين الامان وين اللي بيطالبوا
الناس يقولوا روحوا على رفح في الشابوره
في صلاح الدين في الجنينه في خربه العدس
كل يوم بنسمع راض وكلهم نازحين يعني هذا
البيت في نازحين احنا هذا كله ا 32 نفر
انا انا وعيالي 32 نفر نازح
في كل المناطق اللي تم قصفها نازحين
شكرا كما استمعنا لشهادات من شاهد ايام من
سكان المنزل المجاور القصف والغارات
الاسرائيليه خلال الايام السابقه على وجه
التحديد زادت وتيرتها في استهداف المنازل
وحتى المناطق التي يؤوي اليها
النازحين ايضا الوضع مع ازدحام السكاني في
مدينه رفح جميع المنا نازل في مدينه رفح
يوجد بها عائلات نزحت سواء من مدينه غزه
او من مناطق اخرى في المنطقه الوسطى
والجنوبيه الى هذه المدينه الامر الذي
يوقع خسائر بشريه كبيره في اي قصف او غاره
اسرائيليه تستهدف المنازل الماهوله
بالسكان في مدينه رفح وايضا في ظل اوضاع
انسانيه صعبه وتكدس مئات الالاف في هذه
المناطق وكما تشاهدون فان المنازل متلاصقه
في بعضها البعض اي ان اي اي غاره
اسرائيليه تستهدف اي منزل فان الضمار كبير
يلحق في المنازل المجاوره اضافه الى
الخسائر البشريه سواء على صعيد عدد
الشهداء او حتى الاصابات واقل منزل في رفح
يؤوي العشرات كل منزل يستضيف عائله او
عائلتين من النازحين الى جانب ايضا
المخيمات التي تؤوي مئات الالاف في مدينه
رفح مع اشتداد وتيره القصف والغارات
الاسرائيليه خلال الايام الماضيه كما
رصدنا نقلت لنا اذا من ركام منزل عائله
حجازي الذي هدمه هذا القصف الاسرائيلي
وسقط عدد من الشهداء في هذا المنزل ومنزل
عائله الهمص كذلك في حي الجنينه في شرق
مدينه رفح شكرا جزيلا لك مؤمن
الشرافي